just over a year ago Congress passed the
new every student succeeds Act ESS a
replaced the lively dislikes No Child
Left Behind Act it did a couple of big
and important things one it got
Washington entirely out of the business
of trying to micromanage school
improvement and also mostly got
Washington out of the business of
telling states which schools are
performing well enough second it created
new support and new opportunities for
school choice it included substantial
new support for charter schooling the
only kinds of schools that got big new
funds in the law and it created a pilot
weighted student funding program that
would allow communities which wanted
have federal dollars follow kids more
easily third look it's still a big law
hundreds of pages long with lots of room
for bureaucratic mischief the bottom
line is it's an improvement it's a good
law that's moving the country in the
right direction but how it works for
kids is going to depend how it's
implemented in Washington and the states
and in communities in the years ahead to
learn more about my take on the every
student succeeds act check the links in
the description below also let us know
what other topics you'd like api
scholars to cover in 60 second